hello everyone my name is arpi sagyan
I'm going to present today the topic how
to start thinking critically this topic
is going to cover three aspects of
thinking critically misleading
statistics it is going we are going to
talk about biases and data and multiple
testing this is a beginner talk for
beginners people who want to start in
the field or are beginners in the field
so it's not too late to leave now
other than that I'm going to start so
I'm going to just show you the numbers
that are in the open source data sets
you might have seen them before now I'm
showing you the slide just to point out
the large scale of numbers that are in
the open source data so data that is
publicly available to everybody because
in the later slides we might have you
might have a question why isn't this so
obvious to us if we are having this bias
isn't it such an obvious thing to see in
our data well it's not that obvious to
see when your scale of data is so large
uh so I'll start about our intuitions in
mathematics
we all have as humans an ingrained
intuition in mathematics we know in our
daily life How likely some things are
and how unlikely things are but when you
use this intuition on a very large scale
of data it can really misfire and be
very erroneous so I'm going to give you
a very simple example here for
statistics consider that we have 23
people and we are asking
um you know what is the probability of
at least two people having the same
birthday
same date
and most people I think would think of
this problem and say there's 365 days in
the year there is no way the likelihood
is very low that 23 people are going to
have the same birthday in a year but in
fact when you do the statistical
calculation the number is 50 so it's
like tossing a coin that's quite a large
number for a lot of people if you are
interested in how to solve this problem
you can follow the link here uh and I'll
give you a more complicated example
where our intuitions can be wrong so I
imagine we have two hospitals Hospital a
and Hospital B we have
um a thousand people have a billion been
applied to both hospitals and we know
that 900 have survived in uh Hospital a
and 800 have survived in hospital B
now simply looking at this statistic you
are going to say all right I'm going to
apply to hospital a as a patient because
it seems from the statistics that they
are having a better survival rate
what if I tell you that's not the whole
information
not every patient that enters the
hospital has the same level of critical
condition some are more sick than others
so in hospital a people in critical
condition were admitted 100 people that
day out of them 30 survived and in
hospital B 400 people with critical
condition and 210 survive now this
changes everything right so we're going
to hospital B from now on so they have a
better survival rate for the critical
condition patient it means Hospital B is
uh more specialized we're going here for
sure now this is called the lurking
variable in statistics it is a hidden
context it's a condition that you look
at the face value of the numbers and you
have an assumption that this is how the
statistic is this is our ranking we can
have this problem in so many fields like
choosing Amazon products uh looking at
any sort of rankings and have the
perception that the numbers we're seeing
are representing the what the real truth
is
uh so I'm where I'm going to classify
the sources that from is often
misinformation into three different
types and we are going to cover a lot of
these things so First Source of
misinformation or misleading statistic
can come from generating the data so
which means uh this is the part where we
are gathering data
in any sort of way it could be scraping
or pulling so we can have better biased
sampling here we can have loaded
questions faulty polling by loaded
questions I mean that when you are
surveying a number of people it is quite
an art to create a survey that isn't
um misleading or uh taking the person's
mind into a certain direction the number
of questions the order of questions and
the formulation of questions is very
important in a survey so simply hearing
that a survey of 1000 people has decided
that this is our conclusion isn't enough
we have to understand who this survey
was
who the survey was made by and what were
the questions asked the next part is
processing data here we can have cherry
picking significance and quality of the
data and data mining this is the part
where we are getting our raw data and
we're making it more readable for our
next step of visualization which is the
communicating data so we're presenting
the data that we have gathered in the
form of charts graphs or reports to the
audience and here we can have issues
with data visualization wrong causality
and hidden context uh now we're going to
talk about a lot of these things in this
next slides but before I move on I'm
going to have a disclaimer I'm going to
show you data that data and charts that
come from real life
I have modified the images to remove any
sources or logos from the images the
reason is that I don't have an agenda I
don't have any political affiliations
I'm just showing you real examples of
misleading information that will shown
to the public I don't want to go into
what the slide what the chart is about
all right so the first and the most
simple basic way we can present data to
the public is a pie chart and and the
obvious thing about a pie chart is that
it has to sum up to a hundred
right in in this one it obviously
doesn't
uh not only doesn't it sum up to a
hundred the other thing that's important
about a pie chart is that the proportion
of the slice has to be correct to the
number that's written on it right if
we're saying something is 50 it has to
be half of the pi so in this pie chart
we're looking it looks like the uh green
slice is the largest but it says the
lowest number so we have two aspects of
the pie chart very wrong here
so I'm not saying that this information
was presented to the public in order to
mislead or lie to them
it could have been just the wrong chart
choice of chart uh I think what happened
there is people were allowed to choose
several candidates and they have
presented it in a wrong chart so they
could could have maybe used the bar
chart and it would have been a better
result
speaking of bar chart
I have two bar charts here that are
presenting the same exact information
but they look drastically differently so
what we are going to look for in a bar
chart that both axises are labeled we're
going to ask the chart to have an
absolutely clear numbers of on our
accesses what they're representing we
want the slices of the axis to be
proportional to the change that is
happening
um we want the numbering to be
consistent and yes and we also want the
bars to be proportional to the change
that they are representing so why does
our chart look so different in those two
and our data looks so different in those
two charts well the access doesn't start
from zero in the first one so it starts
from 3.14
which makes the 2008 number look 10
times less than the 2012 number but if
you look from the in the next chart
where it starts from zero this change is
very small so this can be quite
misleading just showing the chart this
way to the public
and this is a very funny example of the
same issue where the aim was to show the
average height of females by country and
you can see that the tiny Indian women
are scared probably of the huge Latvian
Giants and the reason here again is that
the chart doesn't start from zero the
axis of the Y
and the
bars which in this case are pink women
are grown proportionally not just by
height so it looks like a real giant
um now this is another case of a chart
and I'm sure they are not seeing clearly
the x-axis where the issue is with this
one
um and this is I think quite it was
quite intentional actually because
um the numbers are quite blurry on the
chart when it was presented to the
public in this exact manner
what we are not seeing in the x-axis
well no let me start from the data so
what we're seeing in the data is that we
are having covet cases that looks like
they're decreasing over time the x-axis
is a timeline what we're not seeing in
the chart right now is that the numbers
that are written here are not in
chronological order
so they have switched the bars around to
fit an agenda
so we can also have bar charts lying
down but they should have the same uh
rules as the uh the other bar charts so
here we are looking at information of
calories per product and comparing what
is the
calorie in a specific product of a
company and the company that made the
chart was claiming that it is quite a
large difference when in fact it was
only 70 calories less than the companies
that are the most calorific food another
thing that we're not seeing in this in
this chart which is a bad way of
presenting us the data what food is
compared to what and what is the portion
size
all right moving on to line charts so in
these cases we are also going to look at
the axises but in this graph it's it's
quite all right the axis is not the
issue we are going to ask for
proportional
um distances that the numbers represent
we're going to ask for a title to see an
explanation but what is wrong with this
so this chart is showing us the expenses
increasing for education so tuition room
expenses board expenses and the average
earning from a bachelor's degree and
just comparing these two lines and when
if you look at this chart just by on its
own you would think maybe it's not worth
to go get a bachelor's degree it seems
like my expenses are very high but I'm
not going to get a lot of earning what
is missing from this chart is the rest
of the information about the world what
is the expenses and earnings of people
who are not going to the bachelor's
degree maybe we would see that the
earnings of people have really decreased
so we should be paying attention to all
the contexts
now this is a funny chart made by SAS
statistician his name is written as a
source I don't want to say it because I
might mispronounce it but he was uh
using real life data to present exactly
the point that I'm presenting to you now
that uh data can be mined and it can be
represented to look like there is a
correlation in some things that don't
have a correlation at all so we're
looking here at number of people who
have drowned by Falling in a pool and
Nicolas Cage movies
so yes it looks like we have quite a
correlation there and so wonderfully
put together and it are people really
drowning in pools because of Nicolas
Cage and the issue here is that the
data is really mined this is called
cherry picking when you are picking a
specific section of data to just
represent what you are looking for so
this kind of uh things are important to
look for because when
researchers are asked to find something
it is really easy to go after a wrong
correlation and not do a complete test
here is another one just to make sure
that you know that this wasn't the fluke
he can do this many times he has a lot
of other charts and this is the per
capita cheese consumption versus number
of people who died were becoming Tangled
in their bed sheets I didn't know that
was possible so again an example of
cherry picking we are going to talk
about cherry picking more later
um okay so we have another line chart
here and in this line chart it looks
like
there was some pivotal Point like in
2015 there and something drastically
happened and there was a huge decrease
uh in our data
um that's what it looks like when you
just have a quick glance but if you look
at it again the chart is upside down
the y-axis zero is on the top
I'm going to turn that around for you to
visualize it easier and you can see here
that the numbers are indeed going up so
we should be
truly looking at the Y chart every time
we see any sort of representation
moving towards hidden contexts
I'm a lot of you would have heard this
advertisement that 80 percent of
dentists recommend and insert name of
the brand of a toothpaste
so what they're not telling you here is
how can all of this toothpaste companies
claim that 80 percent of dentists are
recommending specifically them uh how
many Genesis tell what is the percentage
of there is a 200 percent of dentists
and then then you figure out that the
lurking condition here is that the
dentists weren't asked to pick a brand
they were asked is it good to brush your
teeth or no
uh with toothpaste versus water
and then that was what they were
answering to and they could also pick
several brands that they thought was a
good brand to use so the eighty percent
of dentists recommend doesn't mean
our brand over everybody else they just
recommend a brand
all right another form of information to
look at when you are looking at any sort
of research you have to know who it was
funded by who it was uh conducted by and
in this case the participants uh you
know they inform the participants that
the research was being performed by
independent research company and in fact
it wasn't
um here this one I think this one gets
most people
um so this has a nutrition label and
here we are seeing that our food product
has
nearly two calories it has zero fat zero
sodium zero carbs zero sugar zero
protein okay sounds great uh yes in fact
what is it and then what you're not
reading in this is the the tiny
disclaimer over there that says not a
significant source of nutrients Which is
less than 0.05 grams so by law if there
is a something in your food that is less
than 0.5 grams they don't have to write
it on the label
okay so what the companies have done
there is they have decreased the serving
size over there to 0.49 so they don't
have to write anything on the label at
all and the serving size in the
container is 200 pieces
so you should really look at the items
you're buying let's say sugar free I
think you would find a lot of things
that are completely made of sugar but
get away with saying a incorrect portion
size
all right now that was the fun part of
the presentation I'm going to move on to
biases and data and we're going to talk
about confirmation bias cherry picking
survival selection availability and
causality biases
now cherry picking we mentioned this one
before it was the Nicholas Cage movies
case where it is a fallacy of selective
attention where we are picking specific
data out of all the data that we have to
represent a certain narrative
um and we are underestimating the
importance of the cases that are not
supporting the hypothesis
what is a confirmation bias it is
actually a type of cherry picking uh
confirmation bias is the tendency to
search for interpret or favor
information that confirms one's prior
beliefs
so we have a belief about something and
whatever data we are seeing we are
interpreting it in a way that is
confirming our beliefs
sorry
so this is very important when
interpreting any sort of data reports
when testing a hypothesis as a
researcher you shouldn't go into the
hypothesis already having made your mind
what this thing is is going to be at the
end and this is one of the biases that I
think we see mostly in our daily life
more than others
a sampling bias I have a funny cartoon
for it so the cartoon says that they
have asked people if they liked
answering surveys or no and
um they a lot of people have said yes I
love answering surveys what they're not
seeing here is the people who don't like
answering service so they don't answer
surveys
so this is the sampling bias that it is
a bias that occurs when looking at
samples that are not representative of
the whole population right you're taking
a small sample of the population and
then scaling out and scaling it up to
the whole population and claiming that
this is what everybody thinks
um and it can be in the cases where our
data is not truly randomized
all right so I'll give you two examples
of this if you're thinking that this is
not so common so most surveys and
statistics come from European countries
because they are being done by European
research companies so when they say 90
of people feel this way about this topic
that's 90 of Europeans that's who they
have surveyed and a lot of Statistics
are based on students because surveys
are usually done for a small amount of
money please come to our survey we'll
give you some some amount of money and
students are often doing this surveys to
get an uh some extra money
all right the next one is how much time
okay the next one is survival bias
uh survival bias is The Logical error of
concentrating on data points that have
made it past a certain selection point
I'm sure a lot of you have seen this
graph if not I'll explain it it is from
the World War II
um where this are these are the planes
that are coming back to the country uh
and they have been harmed severely some
of them they have like bullet holes all
over them well not all over in very
specific places the bullet holes
and the Army looked at the planes and
said okay we are we're going to make
them better we are going to cover those
parts with more armor so the planes are
more protected and put less cover on the
parts where there aren't any bullet
holes to make it more mobile a lighter
plane until the statisticians stopped
them and said that you have a Survivor
bias here because the planes you are
gathering data from are the ones that
returned to your base
exactly
so this statistician said that this is
the exact issue that the uh if you had a
bullet hole in in the parts where are
currently white that plane would have
crashed and it wouldn't have made it
back so you should put in the armor on
the engine the propellers Etc
uh all right
so which is typically because of lack of
visibility this is mostly for also
marketing
a lot of marketing is based on the
success success stories of current
companies we are looking at the cases of
Coca-Cola of Adidas and other companies
and are saying we should be replicating
their strategies to get ahead in the the
market well the truth is that a lot of
these strategies have been done by other
companies as well but they have failed
the issue is that we don't know about
these companies
uh and then the sad one example is when
you're touring uh ruins of old cities
um most likely it is not at all what
that City used to look like these are
the most stable the most
um uh
well-built buildings that have survived
and most of them would have demolished
Through Time
another one availability bias so the
availability bias is the human tendency
to think that examples that you can come
up with readily in your mind are
representative of the actual world
so if you're seeing a lot of airplane
crashes in the news but you're not
thinking of that every time there is an
airplane crash it makes the news but you
are not thinking of the
millions of uh airplanes landing safely
in every country so so this kind of
increases the probability of this
happening in your head uh so there is
another example of shark bites in
certain areas when the probability of a
shark bite in the same area reduces
drastically after there is one case but
because we can recall that there was
shark bite here we are not never going
in that water again
another example is hacking if a company
becomes hacked they are most likely
going to increase their security tenfold
never to happen again but we are going
to lose all confidence in the company
and never trust our data to them
so the causality bias I think
people have heard about the most like
this this tagline of correlation is not
causation
um so it is the case of overestimating
the degrees of causality between two
events
um even believing that they are uh
causally related I think I wrote that
wrong
um okay I'll rephrase that so we're
estimating the degrees of correlation
between two events I'm thinking that
they are causally related so they are
causing one another we are misregarding
coincidences and misrepresentations like
in the example of the Nicholas Cage
again bringing that chart up again it
would have been ridiculous to say that
one is causing the other even though we
can see correlation in the data uh we
are not thinking of a hidden Factor
there can be a third factor that is
making both of these things happen and
uh by removing one of them we're not
going to remove the other this is
especially important in the field of
medicine
um I'll give you an example of cancer
rate in prosperous countries
so there is an increased number of
cancer in uh prosperous countries and
people were really looking at the
statistic baffled thinking what is
causing it why are people getting more
cancer when they're living in a better
environment they were looking at the
income and how they people would
distribute this income what are they
buying what are they drinking what are
they eating and then it turns out that
the medicine in prosperous countries is
better
so they are curing a lot of the diseases
that would have killed you sooner thus
you are growing old enough to get cancer
because cancer is more prominent in our
old age
so uh correlation here didn't mean
causation so you're not getting cancer
because you are in a uh prosperous
country
and my last topic here is multiple
testing I'm going to give you just a
quick introduction because it's a very
large topic that is very well covered
and you can read about it more so I'm
going to present this comic by the
artist XKCD which perfectly explains the
scenario so when we are doing any sort
of research statistical research we are
looking we are having a hypothesis where
called the null hypothesis and we are
going to test this and either confirm or
reject our null hypothesis now when we
are doing any sort of statistical
research there is a chance that we are
going to be wrong that there is going to
be a false positive meaning that all
researchers have this chance of being
wrong and then the
acceptable probability for us for most
research is called the p-value and it is
usually set to zero point excuse me it
is set to five percent so 0.05
now the important thing to understand
here that that any sort of research done
has a five percent chance of being wrong
just by accident
even though it is actually correct
so in this comic book where having a
rumor that jelly beans cause cancer so
they invite a scientist they give him
all the data and say okay please test it
we have a horrible uh rumor and then
that scientist tests and he says there
is a probability of 95 that jelly beans
don't cause cancer then the rumor comes
back that we heard that one specific
color of jelly beans causes cancer we
don't know which one test for all of
them there are 20 colors we are going to
test for 20 colors of jelly beans on the
same data set which means that we are
increasing our probability of a false
positive here so in this next slide here
we are having a aha moment of the
p-value being less than
0.00.05 and we're saying that the Green
Jelly Bean causes cancer and then the
acne sorry and in the next day in the
news is the first headline the that
green jelly beans are linked to acne
so this is the issue of multiple testing
that most researchers know that their
research has a five percent chance of
being wrong so when you are reading
about studies that have a lot of factors
of or studies that have not been
replicated you have to understand that
there is a chance that it is a false
positive
this is why we have peer reviews for our
papers when people replicate our results
to make sure that this was not just a
coincidence
right thank you
[Applause]
thank you for the presentation so if
there are any questions please raise
your hands
thank you for a great presentation I
just want to ask is it working okay
I just wanted to ask is there any
questions at least that in for every
data you can ask for yourself to think
like
for example the p-value is really high
for your measurements or the way you are
thinking of a data thank you for your
question that's actually a great
question
if there was such a list unfortunately
at least I don't have one I don't know
if it exists but there are known biases
that we can find in our data this is
just some of them there are a lot more
and then as a statistician as a
researcher you're constantly learning
about the biases that can possibly
happen in your data and one of the best
things you can do is have domain
expertise about what you are testing you
would you have more awareness of what
kind of biases can be since your
specific data set
um yes it really depends on the case
and then one thing to also mention is
that there is always going to be bias in
your data well whatever amount of data
you own it is never big enough to
represent the 100 represent the full
population
so you just have to be aware of your
limitations
well if what about if I balance the data
you say Dave if it is biased what about
if I balance the data maybe uh 80 of of
the data is zero and one percent is only
one is only 20 what about if I balance
balance the data over sampling one under
sampling with
there will be no bias anymore in that
that's a great question that is a great
way to remove some of the most of the
biases actually from your data is
balancing it but it doesn't remove for
example the uh selection bias that you
might have that your whole data is is
from a wrong sample it wouldn't account
for that bias it wouldn't account for
your internal bias of confirmation bias
for example when you are
yourself focusing on the wrong thing
when you're doing the statistic you know
your statistical research
and the reason that we all know that
there is always bias in your data is
because even the biggest companies with
the biggest amount of data Google for
example
has still biases in their products and
when when they present the product to
the public we can find as uh researchers
or data scientists we can find these
bugs in in the programs in the models
and say okay they have a biased data for
this person particular thing
thanks for presentation
but what are the solutions of these
biases
I don't know like
said that you can over sample a rounder
sample but for example survival bias or
availability bias what are the solutions
for them right thank you that's a great
question so for a lot of these things
there are solutions that you can do most
of them include adding more data to your
samples having domain expertise
understanding the way that your data is
going to be used later to to
see some of the devices that are
possible and there are some very good
statistical techniques to see how your
well your data represents the true
population
but for uh
a lot of these things you just have to
know that there there are going to be
biases or know that there is a specific
bias in your data and account for this
limitation for example if you have a
survival bias that means that this data
doesn't exist in real life for you to
test it on so you are a marketing
research person you are gathering
information about the marketing of other
companies and you cannot possibly gather
the information from companies who have
failed who are not here to tell us their
stories so you need to write a
disclaimer in your research or explain
this to the client that you are making
the product for that there is a bias in
our data there is a survival bias and
then we need to take this into account
okay
okay thank you for the presentation I
would like to ask as you said
all data mostly that are presented to
the public is biased so how can you rely
on the data you find on the internet and
how to choose between the most reliable
companies and understand which the data
to choose and to test on I right yes I
presented a very scary presentation I
think I have removed all faith in
humanity with this but the truth is that
not all companies are trying to mislead
us and that is a great question though
because you really always have to do
your own research if you're reading a
title that is going to change your
Viewpoint about a specific topic you
should really read the poll paper
because we are always getting this
propensity to have a click paid title so
a lot of the researchers have would have
articles be on their papers would have
articles that are this huge title that I
don't know we're dying tomorrow and you
and you have to click on the paper read
the paper and see what it's about
thank you
all right
could you please explain again what is
availability bias with more examples
all right here so we'll do Beauty biases
the human Humanity to think that uh
things that come in your head easily
examples that you can recall easily are
more prominent than others so if I ask
you a question and then you answer the
first thing that comes to your head you
might think that this is the most common
thing that is happening around you when
in fact you don't have the full data you
don't know if it is or not the
difference between survival bias and
availability bias is that this for
survival bias the data isn't there so so
you can't really confirm but for
availability biases that you will have
the perception the wrong perception
about the full data you haven't seen it
all right
thank you everyone
thank you
[Applause]